a turtle shell is as much a part of its
body as our ribcage is of ours in fact
it is their ribcage and their spine and
their vertebrae and their sternum
basically a turtle skeleton is inside
out and just like you can't take a
skeleton out of a person right you can't
take a turtle out of its shell either
but if you could you'd probably be
surprised by what you discover here's
the inside of a turtle that's Maria
Wojciechowski a biologist who's been
studying turtle ecology for more than a
decade
here's your shoulder girdle here's your
hip girdle notice how those hips and
shoulders are actually inside the
turtles ribcage turtles are one of the
only land animals on the planet with
this feature they're also some of the
only animals that can breathe with their
butts you see inside a turtle shell is a
very particular respiratory system you
will see the lungs towards the top here
now most land animals breathe by
expanding and contracting their ribs
which creates a natural pump that guides
air in and out of their lungs but
Turtles can't do this because they're
rigid shells don't expand so instead
they rely on sheets of muscles within
their shell to pump in oxygen through
their mouths that is most of the time
then there are other times when turtles
breathe out the other end
more specifically through what
scientists call the cloaca it's the same
opening that Turtles used to urinate
defecate and lay eggs and in some cases
it can double as a set of gills sucking
in water and absorbing the oxygen within
scientists think that Turtles do this
when they're spending long periods of
time underwater like when they're
hibernating and if you look really
closely at the inside of a shell you'd
discover another feature that helps with
hibernating underwater
scaffold like structure that can store
and release chemicals that structure
actually helps turtles breathe without
any oxygen at all it works like this
many turtles hibernate in frozen ponds
that are starved of oxygen and to
survives their metabolism switches over
from aerobic to anaerobic that means
they stop using oxygen for energy and
start using glucose instead via a
process called
anaerobic respiration and the byproduct
of that is lactic acid now theoretically
this acid could build up in a turtles
body and kill it that's where the shells
structure comes in it can absorb the
lactic acid as well as release a
bicarbonate to neutralize that acid it's
essentially tums
but for turtles so as it turns out
having a shell is pretty handy for
certain situations in fact scientists
think that turtles originally got their
shells for digging likely more than 200
million years ago so you take like
really really complex burrowing
structures underground
and of course shells are incredibly
useful for a defense against predators
no matter how fierce they may be turtles
are amazing